welcome to part
two of the tutorial on pseudo boolean
solving and optimization
this is part of the boot camp for the
satisfiability
theory practice and beyond program at
the simons institute for the theory of
computing
in part one we covered some
preliminaries
now in part two we're going to talk
about pseudo-boolean solving
that is how do we determine whether a
pseudo boolean formula
a collection of zero one linear
inequalities is
satisfiable or not and we're going to
use as our starting point the conflict
driven paradigm
used in stat solving and therefore we're
going to start by reviewing
how a cdcl solar works so that next we
can talk about
how we can use this to do pseudo boolean
solving
either by translating the pseudo-boolean
problem
to cnf so that we can run a cdcl solver
on it
or in the in the other direction
lift the cdcl reasoning to
pseudo boolean constraints to get what i
will call a native suru boolean solver
or a cutting planes based pseudo boolean
solver
so modern stat solving started in the
1960s with the dpl
method uh which works so that you
assign values to variables you try to
choose them in some smart way
until you uh discover that accidentally
you you happen to falsify clause and
then you backtrack and try something
else
what led to the modern revolution in sat
was then
when to this framework was added
the idea to learn
from the conflicts leading to conflict
driven close learning
where every time you happen to falsify a
clause you don't just want to backtrack
you want to derive some explanation for
the failure and you add this as a new
clause to the formula
and this will provably
lead to a potentially an exponential
improvement
in the search because you can cut off
large parts of the search space you can
avoid
making the same mistake elsewhere in
your search base
and an important part of conflict-driven
clause learning sat solvers is that
the statistics the information gathered
from this conflicts will also guide
other aspects of
how the solver is being used we're not
going to talk so much about that but
we're going to focus on the basics
of conflict-driven clause learning how
to assign values to variables
and then analyze the conflicts when
things go wrong
so here is an example formula just to
make sure we're on the same page
the first clause says that u or x
or y must be true or one and then the
second clause says that
x must be true or y must be false bar
denotes negation or is that must be true
and then we have
a bunch of other clauses and they're all
added together so we're looking for an
assignment
to an assignment
zero one assignment to these variables
that will satisfy all of these clauses
if there is such an assignment we want
the solver to find it
if there is no satisfying assignment we
want the solver to report that so as
you're
listening to this talk you can quickly
try to think for yourself is this a
satisfiable or an unsatisfiable formula
we'll try to run a sat solder on this to
figure out
and the sat solver when it makes
variable assignments it has two
different ways of making assignments one
of them
are called decisions this is when we
just make a free choice
to assign a value to a variable say the
solver for some reason likes w
it picks w and it sets it to zero and
we'll
write it in this way that w equals
zero and that's a decision decision
that's why we have this
d on top okay good
now the solver takes a look at the
formula and it sees
that actually given that w is false
there is a clause which has only one
non-falsified literal left and this is
the clause not u
or w we can see that the
value of u is now forced we have to set
w we have to set u
to false or else this clause will be
falsified so this is called the unit
propagation
and so we will always unit propagate
such choices because otherwise we'll
immediately run into conflict and the
notation here is that we set
u to zero as explained by the clause
not u or w and we say that not u or w
is the reason for this propagation
okay so we add this to
the partial assignment that the solver
is building
here on the left of the slide
and then we look at the formula if there
are any further propagations
turns out that there are no further
propagation so
the solver makes a decision again so we
always propagate until saturation
but then we make a decision and now the
solver for some reason decides that
it wants to set x to false and now we
see that since
both u and x are false the first clause
propagates y to true
and now we get a chain of propagations
because now the second clause since
x is true and y is
false this propagates zed to true
but now we have a contradiction with a
fourth clause which wanted
y or z to be false both of them have
been set to true
so during the search phase the forward
phase we always
propagate if possible otherwise we
decide until
well either we find a satisfying
assignment but here we run into a
conflict so we have a conflict clause
y or z is a conflict clause so
now we have to do conflict analysis
and one thing we could do what a dpll
solver would have done
it would just have said okay clearly
setting x to false was a bad decision
let me
reverse it and try to set x to true
instead
but in conflict-driven close learning we
want to be smarter we want to
learn a new clause from the conflict so
that we can avoid this mistake in the
future
and we do this by a case analysis over
the last
two clauses we see that the the conflict
clause
turned into a conflict clause because it
wanted zed to be false
but the reason clause for said being
true
wanted z to be true so these two clauses
have opposite opinions about z
so we can merge these two clauses
and remove said because we see that
any satisfying assignment if there were
a satisfying assignment satisfying these
two clauses
then such an assignment would also have
to satisfy
x or not y
just by case analysis over z so note
that we have now derived a new clause
that is not in our formula
but it's a clause that has to be true
in any satisfying assignment of the
formula
so it's a valid consequence from the
formula
now we continue we look at this new
clause
x or not y which is
unhappy because y is
true y is true because of the clause u
or x or y so we can resolve these two
clauses over y
to get u or x
which is another clause that we didn't
know but that is implied by the formula
so we repeat this um
going back on the so-called trail of
assignments
looking at the reason clauses and
resolving them
until we get a clause where there's only
one variable left
that was propagated after the last
decision
or was decided as the last decision and
here we see that we actually have such a
clause now because
x was the last decision but u was
assigned
earlier in the search so this is called
a
unique implication point clause or a uip
clause and says this was the first such
clause that we encountered during the
conflict
analysis it is the first uip clause so
we learn that clause
and then we back jump now what do we do
when we back jump
we roll back decisions
[Music]
so that this learned clause
is no longer false but so that it
propagates
so we undo the decision on x and we do
undo all the propagations after that but
we keep
the decision on w being false and the
propagation of u being false
and under this assignment we see that
this learned clause
propagates it propagates now that x must
be true it flips the value
of x compared to what we had before
so this now x being true immediately
propagates
that z must be
true according to the third clause
but then the fifth clause gets unhappy
because it wanted either x or z to be
true
so we have another conflict here the
conflict analysis
is very simple we just resolve these two
clauses over
z they they have a different opinions
about z but they both contain not x
the only way of satisfying both of these
clauses is
to set x to false
so we're actually changing our opinion
about x again here
and now since this clause contains
a single literal we back jump all the
way to the top without making any
decisions
and now we start unit propagating again
note that we have learned a clause the
so-called unit clause contains only one
literal
and that clause propagates that x must
be false
and then the other clause that we
learned
u or x now propagates that u
must be true but that propagates
according to the next to last clause
that
w must be true but then the very last
clause wanted w to be false
so now we have a conflict again
and note that we have run into a
conflict without
making any decisions we have just
added clauses that were implied by our
formula and then we have made obvious
unit propagations
and these obvious unit propagations lead
to a conflict
they lead to contradiction so this means
that at this point
the solver can conclude that the formula
is unsatisfiable
however just as a mental exercise we can
try to run this conflict analysis again
just to see what happens and
by resolving the last two clauses we
derive that u
must be false we derive the unit clause
not u then we derive the unit clause
x which is already looking fishy because
we have a unit clause
not x before and by case analysis over
that we get
contradiction
so again in
practice the solver would not do this
final
derivation from the last conflict
because it already knows
that it will derive contradiction but we
could do it mentally and we'll see
uh in a bit why we might want to do this
so at a high level here is
how a cdcl solver works
so if the current assignment falsified
the clause
then we do this conflict analysis we use
some learning scheme
and if we learn a clause without
literals
that is contradiction then we know the
formula is unsatisfiable
otherwise we learn the clause and back
jump
and again note that learning the empty
clauses is
again a just a theoretically nice way of
expressing it
again the solver would terminate before
learning this empty clause because it
knows it will learn the santa clause
okay so if however the current
assignment does not falsify any clause
and if all variables are assigned then
apparently we have satisfying
assignments so we can report that and
exit
otherwise if there is a clause that is
propagating some variable to a value
a unit clause under the current
assignment with only the literal x left
and all other literals false
then we let c propagate x
and add this propagated assignment to
the solver
trail okay
otherwise if there is no propagations
then the solver will think about whether
it should restart the search from the
top remove all variable assignments
otherwise if the restart policy says
that that's not
the what it should do then it checks
whether it's time for
clause database reduction if so it
throws away a lot of the learned clauses
because the modern solver accumulates
lots and lots of clauses so it spends
also a significant amount of time
throwing away clauses that it has
learned otherwise if none of these cases
apply
then we should use some heuristics some
disjusting scheme
to choose some variable x and a boolean
value b
and decide x to b and then check if we
have
any propagation again
and when we translate this to a pseudo
boolean setting we're going to ignore
all these important details
about restarts and database reduction
and how to choose the decisions we're
actually just going to focus on the
conflict analysis
before going there let's make a detour
and just talk about how can we analyze
what a cdcl solver does
so as i already hinted there are lots of
of
sophisticated heuristics and they are
very hard to describe formally and
understand so
what seems to be the best method of
analyzing what cdcl solvers can do is to
focus on the underlying method of
reasoning and somehow assume that the
heuristics can use this method of
reasoning really efficiently
and as we could see in the conflict
analysis
what conflict analysis essentially does
it does
case analysis over clauses so and this
is
what is known as the resolution proof
system where we start with the clauses
of a formula
and we derive new clauses by the
resolution rule which is a case analysis
over x essentially if we have a clause c
or x and another clause d or not x
then by case analysis if both of these
clauses are true
then c or d must also be true so we can
derive c or d as a new clause and then
we keep going
until if f is satisfiable we derive
contradiction in the form of an empty
clause
so when a cdcl solver is run on an
unsatisfiable formula it in fact
generates a resolution proof
so this means that if we have a formula
for which we know
that there can be no short resolution
proofs
then that also provides a lower bound
limit on the running time of a cdcl
solver because
the cdcl solder will in principle have
to find
a resolution proof no matter whether
it's outputs this proof or not
and if we know that there are no short
proofs say that the best proofs there
are exponentially long then that means
cdcl solvers have to run
for exponential time now
importantly this is ignoring the issue
of pre-processing
which are some shortcuts that cdcl
solvers make
at the start and that are not
necessarily captured
by the resolution proof system
and this is an important area but we
don't have time to go into it
and still even with this cavity it seems
fair to say that the resolution proof
system is pretty good
at characterizing what cdcl solvers can
do
in practice how
does this then relate to the
execution of a cdcl server well if we
take this dry run that we had
and here are the conflict analysis and
here are the learned clauses
and we just add arrows
showing how the learned clauses
are used in later conflict analysis and
string all of this together
then it can in fact be shown that this
yields a valid resolution proof
and this is not just in this example
this is a general fact
so from any cdcl execution we get a
resolution proof
so what brings us here from this
for this program at the simons institute
is the fact that state-of-the-art cdcl
sat solvers
are amazingly good so as a computational
complexity
theorist i was taught to think about sat
as a hard problem exponentially hard but
practitioners think about
sad as often being easy in practice so
this raises the question of how
how can this be possible and we don't
have a very good theoretical
understanding of this
why these heuristics work and why
the instances that we encounter in
applications are easy
because the paradox is that resolution
is a fairly weak proof systems
so there are many strong lower bounds
for different formulas
as in these references and by the way i
should mention that i'm dumping
quite a few references in these slides
they are all at the end of the slides
full
bibliographic references so if you get
hold of the slides
from the simon's institute web page you
can check the references there
or else at the end of the fourth video
with the fourth
part of this tutorial i will also go
through
the pages with the references so that
you can find them there
so resolution is quite a weak proof
system and in fact there are
problems where it doesn't seem to be
enough there are problems where cdcl
solvers are not fast
and where the explanation is that
resolution is provably not just strong
enough
so the obvious question is whether we
can then
harness stronger methods of reasoning
and in particular the reason that
we're here that i'm giving this tutorial
and that you're listening to it
is that pseudo-boolean solving which is
just
in principle another name for zero one
interior linear programming
is such a stronger method that
corresponds to what the so-called
cutting planes proof system can do and
i'll talk about that
in a minute and even more interestingly
not only is cutting planes more powerful
than resolution
for cnf formulas but cutting planes also
allows us to go from just decision
problems
to the richer class of optimization
problems and this is
a topic that we will return to in part
three
of this tutorial okay
so now we have seen how cdcl solvers
work
and now we want to apply this to a
pseudo-boolean formula recall that a
pseudo-boolean formula is a collection
of pseudo-boolean constraints that is
zero one interlinear
integer linear inequalities
so one simple way
of doing sudo boolean solving is to
read it in your pseudo-boolean formula
and then
whenever it propagates you provide
a disjunctive clause that explains the
propagation
and then essentially you just run
a cdcl solver the only difference is
that the original
constraints in your formula are pb
constraints but you don't
see this because the reasons you put on
the trail
are clauses and for instance the set4j
solver supports this
so this is not so interesting we won't
talk about it but the more
interesting this is kind of a lazy
approach where you generate clauses
as you need them but and a more eager
approach is to take your pseudo boolean
formula
rewrite it into conjunctive normal form
to an equi-satisfiable formula and
run a cd salesforce on it and this was
explored in minnesota
plus and two good modern solver for
solvers for this are open wbo and naps
and we'll talk a little bit about this
but then what
i am really interested in and working on
and will
try to get you excited about is to
instead use
native reasoning with pseudo-boolean
constraints
which has been explored in prs galena
and pueblo for instance and the two
modern solvers that i am aware of that
are doing this are
sat4j by the group in lans and
rounding sat which is from my research
group
so in particular in what follows i will
talk about
sat4j and rounding saturn what goes what
happens
inside these solvers but before doing so
we'll talk about
this first approach the eager
re-encoding to cnf in order to run
cdcl solver so
we have to first talk about how to do
this rewriting to cnf because we saw in
the tutorial
that there can be an exponential
explosion when you
rewrite a pseudo boolean constraints
just a cardinality constraint saying
that out of these
n variables at least half of them are
true
this will be an exponentially large cnf
formula and this won't do
so what we do to circumvent this is to
introduce
new variables extension variables and
they allow us to get a more compact
encoding
and one way of thinking about this is
that the new variables that we can
we can think of writing down a circuit
that evaluates whether the pseudo
boolean constraint is true
and the new variables and clauses in our
cnf formula will just be constraints
forcing the circuit to be evaluated
correctly so since it is simpler and
since
it is not the main focus of this
tutorial i will focus on cardinality
constraints
so these are pseudo-boolean constraints
where all the coefficients are one
and and only a little bit talk about how
to generalize this to to arbitrary
pseudo boolean constraints and
so we have this we're summing up
variables
x from x1 to xn and we're comparing them
to
k maybe a greater than constraint maybe
a
less than equal constraint maybe
inequality okay how can we do this
one simple idea is to introduce
counter variables sij
with the intended meaning that the sum
of the i
first variables x1 up to x i
is at least j
and the base case so we we have a sort
of inductive encoding here where the
base case
is that well s11
the sum of the first variable is at
least one that's true exactly when
x is true so i write down that s11 is
true
if if x is true and x 1 1 has to be
false
if x is false so this is here is an
implication saying that if
if x 1 is true that forces x 1 1 to true
and if x 1 is false that forces x11 to
false
and of course for j strictly larger than
one we're just adding
unit clauses that the first
variable cannot sum to j for j greater
than one which is
hopefully clear and now suppose that
we've defined
all uh variables um
for s i minus 1 and j
then we say that well if
x i is true then
the sum of the i first variable is at
least one
and if the sum of the i f minus one
first variable is already j then
certainly the sum of the i
first variable variables is also j
so more interestingly if here's an
implication saying that if
x i is true and if
the sum of the i minus first variables
is j then in fact the the sum
of the i first variables is j plus one
and then we add the reverse constraint
saying that well the only
way that the sum of the i uh first
variables can be j plus 1 is either
that that was already the case for the i
minus
1 first variables or if not then x i has
to be true and s
minus 1 j also has to be true
so it should hopefully be clear that
if we concatenate all of these clauses
then we will
get s and
k will uh given any truth value
assignments to the x variables
x and k will correctly encode
whether it is in fact the case that
um out of these end variables k of them
are true
so we'll just take any we can take any
uh assignment to the x variables and and
they will just propagate through these
clauses
so if we want to enforce a cardinality
constraint
sum of x1 to xn greater equal k we do
this by having this encoding and then
just adding a unit clause
claiming that this has to be true and
similarly if we want the less than equal
constraint for k
then we just add the unit clause saying
that the sum does not
reach k plus one and for inequality we
add both of these
so this is a simple encoding to explain
if you think about it it's not a very
good encoding where somehow
it's a as circuits go it's a very
unbalanced circuit we
are adding new bits one at a time
if you think about it we can do some
more kind of divide and conquer approach
where we build a binary tree where we
sum up
the bits pairwise and then we sum up
them maybe four
by four and then eight by eight this is
what's known as the
totalizer encoding where we we can
visualize it at a binary tree
where the children have t bits let's say
a i and bi
and each parent outputs two t
bits cj which is the number of
of ones it sees in these ais and bis
so we should think of cj as as
the analog of the s variables from the
previous slide that
cj is true precisely if the sum of the
input
variables a i and bi are greater equal
j so the base case in the leaves we have
two bits and there the output is that
well if either x1 or x2 is true then
clearly
one bit is true if both x1 and x2 are
true then in fact the sum is two
and then conversely we say the only way
that
at least one
bit is true is that if one bit is true
or conversely if x1 and
x2 are both false then this in fact
forces c1 to be false
and the only way
c2 can be true if is if both x1 and x2
are true
and then the inductive step will just be
it's very simple if from on the a
a side we have i bits
true and on the b side we have j bits
true then
we set as the output bit that c i plus j
has to be true
but the only way
that c i plus j
plus 1 can be true if you think about it
is that either a i plus 1 is true
or b j plus 1 is true so if
both of these are false uh
then it cannot be the case that that we
sum up
to i plus j plus one bits in the output
and here we're assuming
um um like default values a zero b b0
equals one so i'm going a bit quickly
over
these things there will be some other
technical details later in the talk that
are also a bit fast and the reason for
this is i hope
you can hit the pulse button and and
think over this so i won't explain this
further
but but instead move on okay
and again the idea is that how to
enforce a carnality constraint we just
add for the root node the unit clause ck
if we have a greater equal k constraint
and if we have a less equal k constraint
when
we add the unit clause not c k plus one
and this um can in fact be extended to
to arbitrary uh pseudo boolean
constraints something that is known as
the generalized
totalizer encoding although
the size of this encoding uh can be
a bit bad the blow up can be pretty bad
in the in the worst case
okay so what do you do then if the blow
up is bad well it turns out that there's
also a
completely uh general encoding that will
i that i will just sketch that basically
builds an other circuit to evaluate the
general sudo boolean constraints so
here's a general pseudo-boolean
constraint some ai
li for literals li greater equal a so we
focus on this linear form
on the left-hand side and we think of
the
coefficients ai as being returned in
binary where throughout this slide we
just imagine that b
is large enough for for everything to
hold that i'm going to say
so peak b large enough and maybe the
largest most significant bits here will
all be zero
but the point is that i want to be able
to sum the ai's and still fit
in b bits okay so
with this binary representation it's
kind of trivial to make the first
observation that a i
l i summing over i is equal to summing
over i
and then summing over the bits j
2 to the j times the bit
a i j which is a not a variable this is
like a
a constant that is known at compile time
because we know what these coefficients
are times the literal li
okay so this is just two ways of writing
this same constraint
and now what we do in other network
encoding
is we start with the least significant
bit
so the bit in position zero and we check
where which bits we have where
which literals appear with
an odd coefficient and then we just
start to add them up
by encoding full adders so we take any
two bits
or any three bits actually in
and one bit out and then a carry
so these are s out and c out or are new
variables so note that this
eliminates um
three bits of the least significant
position and we add one back
and then we do this with full adders or
half adders until there's only one
bit s left in the least significant
position and all the others have
moved to the next to uh least
significant position
by carries and then we start taking care
of that position
um using that bucket it's emptying that
bucket in in the insurance on
terminology which presented this
encoding
and we do this so basically we just
write down in cnf a full adder for this
whole expression
and then in the end we will have a cnf
encoding enforcing that this
this linear form sum of a ili which
could be written in this
as this exponential sum will be summing
from j
goes from 0 to b 2 to the j
times s sub j where s j are the output
variables and then we have lots and lots
of other specifications forcing these sj
to the correct values
okay and once we have these we can also
write down
cnf formulas forcing this number
uh sum two to the j times
sj for variables sj should be greater
equal a
if we're doing a pseudogoolin greater
than constraint
in normalized form recall that we're
always assuming when
we're dealing with pseudo-boolean
constraints unless stated otherwise that
they are in normalized form
meaning that all the ai's and a are
non-negative
okay i think obviously this is a a is a
i'm skipping like most of the
interesting details and you can see the
answers on paper
from 2006 uh to
to read up on these details
what do we want from these cnf encodings
well
one thing is what is referred to as
generalized arc consistency we want them
to propagate so
if i have a partial assignment row
and if this original sudo boolean
constraint
c propagated a value under row
then the c f encoding f sub c
should propagate the same values okay
and in particular if rho
falsifies the pseudoboolean constraint c
then
it probably won't falsify
f sub c but f sub c should his unit
propagate
to falsity to contradiction okay so this
is a desirable property this sort of
means that from a
propagation point of view and the solver
is deciding and propagating
it doesn't really matter whether it's
using the pseudo boolean constraint
or the cnf encoding because it's seeing
the same propagations
kind of sort of okay so sequence the
sequential counter encoding and the
totalizer encoding that we talked about
have this generalized or consistency
property other networks
do not so they're worse in this regard
but generalized our consistency is not
everything encoding size is another
property that we care a lot about
we want polynomial size and ideally as a
small polynomial as possible
and here other networks really shine
that's an extremely compact encoding
totalizer encodings are
not as good but they have at least fewer
variables than sequential encoding and
this is because this
binary tree divide and conquer
however generalized totalizer encodings
can get exponentially large
so in that's the respect they're
incomparable to other networks
they have better propagation properties
but can a much worse size
in fact it is possible to achieve both a
generalized our consistency in
polynomial size encodings
but this appears to be mostly a
theoretical result
and the the generalized totalizer paper
reports
that um the the generalized totalizer
encoding in practice seems to be at
least
as good but i'm only scratching the
surface here
it's it's in fact the case that this
this question of how to encode
uh constraints into cnf that's a
research area in its own there's a rich
literal
literature on this and so i you can
refer to the sat
handbook to find more references on this
so how does this perform well
the approach of taking a pseudo-boolean
formula re-encoding the constraints into
cnf and running a cdcl
solver can be really really good uh in
fact
it sometimes beats the native
pseudo-boolean solvers that i'm going to
talk about later hands down
and so what is the explanation for this
so we don't
have a really clear understanding but
one
simple observation is that we know that
extension variables gives
a solver a lot of power now we're
introducing all these extra variables
that we're talking about partial sums
so this gives um the solver a way of
branching over fairly complex statements
like the partial sum
of the half of the variables is at least
halfway to what i would like to get
there's no way a native pseudo-boolean
solver can say that because it doesn't
have such a variable to branch over
and when you start composing these
variables into
into clauses if you think about it since
every variable
is semantically a linear inequality
then a clause over such um
literals corresponds can correspond to
some kind of
generally shaped polytope so this is
very powerful
and this is maybe an explanation why the
cdcl-based approach to pseudobuddhist
holding can be so good
however we've can also see that
in order for this to work you somehow
want a friendly encoding for instance so
that
so that variables that are somehow
related in the instance
are close to each other in the surubulen
encoding so that they get picked up
by like close to each other in the cnf
encoding and help propagation
and if you so for instance if you take a
pseudo-boolean form line you just
randomly permute
say the variable indices or flip some
science
and then run this uh
translation of the pseudo boolean
constraints somatically exactly the same
constraints into c enough but just
because of this rounding
random permuting that causes a
terrible hit in in performance
and also you can argue from a
theoretical point of view that for some
problems there is no way
these extension variables can make up
for the loss
in the reasoning power of cdcl compared
to
pseudo-boolean reasoning um
so some open
questions about this cdcl based approach
for for pseudo boon installing one
um somewhat intriguing um
question is that the way i presented
these encodings are
in fact not exactly the way they're
written in the papers
so you have the the the clauses that do
the propagation there's a
kind of forward propagation which says
that if i have an assignment to the xs
that so that at least k xi's are true
then the encoding should forward
propagate this counter the final counter
variable to true that's
sometimes referred to as forward
propagation backward propagation would
be in the other direction
namely that if if i have an assignment
so that enough excises
are false like if if n
minus k plus 1 x size or false then i
should propagate
that the cardinality constraint is in
fact false
and this is a referred to backward
propagation so the the forward
propagation clauses you see are in green
on this slide
and below that you have the backward
propagation process in red
and in fact in my understanding
although i haven't worked on this but my
understanding is that
the solvers that do this rewriting do
the forward propagation clauses but not
necessarily the backward propagation
clauses and it's a natural question to
ask whether
it would help to add both forward and
backward propagation clauses
or there presumably was some reason why
for instance open wbu
chose not to do this so does it actually
hurt performance if so why
can it be that too much propagation
actually hurts you that you don't want
this
some more questions well an obvious
question from from the discussion so far
is how do we find a good encoding is
there a best possible encoding how do we
do this
trade-off between propagation strength
and encoding side can we say something
you know can we bring tools from
computation complexity
theory to to bear on this and say
something intelligent
can we understand this observation that
cdcl-based solvers are sometimes so much
better than
native pseudo-boolean solvers and
sometimes not can we
provide some theoretical computational
complexity results explaining this
from a more applied point of view could
we somehow combine the strength of
rewriting and cutting planes based
reasoning
and a final question that is
somewhat interesting if you think about
it in practice because this rewriting
it's there's going to be a lot of
rewriting before you get
to running the cdcl solver on your
rewritten um
pseudo boolean problem how do we know
that we're solving the right problem how
do we actually know that the
re-encoding of the pseudo-boolean
constraints into cnf
was correct can we somehow certify this
can we prove this this is an also
an interesting question and the current
state of the arch seems to be that we
just have to
trust that this re-encoding is
is done correctly
okay so this is what i wanted to say
about cdcl
based pseudo boolean solving
now we turn to what i refer to as native
pseudo-boolean
conflict-driven search uh where we
we we won't rewrite the constraints to
cnf
we will operate on them natively
will massage the linear inequalities and
such
okay but except for that we want to do
sort of the same thing as
conflict-driven close learning so what
does that mean
well we want to do variable assignments
we want to propagate when possible
and then we make an assignment and then
propagate until saturation
okay and when we reach a conflict we
want to do conflict analysis
to learn a new constraint and we want to
add this
new learned constraint to the
the other constraint that we have in our
formula instance and then we want to
back jump just as a cdcl solver but now
the question is
how does this work what does it mean
that uh uh pseudo boolean constraints
propagates or
or what would it mean to do suitable and
conflict analysis this is what
we have to figure out
so
i will use row to refer to the current
assignment of the solver which is also
referred to as the trail
and not only is this a an assignment but
it also contains the information
it's an ordered assignment because the
assignments were made in some
chronological order and for every
assignment we know
whether it is a decision or whether it
was propagated
and if it was propagated we've written
down which constraint propagated it
an important notion for pseudo
pseudobullet constraints is slack
and a slack of a constraint under a
partial
truth value assignment row measures how
far
rho is from falsifying this constraint
so how far is row from falsifying it
well you take
all the literals that have not been
falsified literals that are
true or could be made true
you take those literals and you sum up
the a i's of these literals that's like
the maximal contribution that you could
get from the left-hand side
and then you subtract the degree of
falsity
again here for the slack definition it's
very important that we're using
normalized form so all of the
integers here are non-negative this is
one example why it's so convenient to
talk about normalized form because the
slack definition
gets so much cleaner of course we can
always define slack
for pseudo boolean constraints but it
gets nicer to
describe what the definition is if we
are allowed to assume
normalized form so assuming normalized
form everything is
is is positive here then the given row
the contribution we can hope from for
from the left-hand side is clearly
summing
overall summing the ai's for all
literals li that are not
falsified by row they're either
satisfied or they
are unassigned and then we subtract
the degree of falsity and that's somehow
the margin of error that we still have
that's the slack
that measures how how nervous we should
be about
falsifying this constraint
so let's go back to this constraint we
had before x one plus two x two bar plus
three x three plus four x four bar plus
five x five great t equals seven and
uh let's let's see what the slack is
well
under the empty assignment we see that
we can sum up
the left hand side to to 15
and the degree of falsity is seven so 15
minus seven is
eight so there's a lot of slack in this
constraint
now suppose that the solver for some
reason
decides to set x5 to false so we extend
the partial assignment we represent the
partial assignment also by
just a collection of literals set to
true by it so x5 is set to false means
that the
assignment row contains not x5 now
we see that x5 gets falsified no longer
contributes to the slack so the slack
drops
from 8 to 3.
and now an interesting observation is
that 3 is less than
4 which is the coefficient of not x4 and
what this means
is that if we
fail to set x4 to the value
that this constraint wants then there's
no way we're going to satisfy this
constraint if you think about it
and you can also see this that if if if
both x5 and x4
are set to the wrong values then the
remaining contribution we can get is one
plus two plus three which is six
which is less than seven and the way we
see this is indeed that the the current
slack
is strictly less than um
some coefficient okay
so that when this happens
the solver should propagate
the literal to true so let's do that
let's propagate x4 to false
let's propagate not x4 to true then
since this is a contribution in the
right direction this doesn't change the
slack so the slack is still three
three we we just got the the
contribution we were asking for
okay then suppose the solver goes off
and
does some other assignments maybe it
sets
x3 2 to false and then it says
x 2 to true because it's looking at some
other constraints
and now we can compute the slack of this
constraint
then x5 doesn't contribute x4
contributes 4
x3 doesn't contribute x2 doesn't
contribute
x1 is unassigned so it still contributes
so the contribution on the left is
5 but we need 7 so the slack is negative
it's minus 2 and what this means
is that there's no way we can satisfy
this constraint
under row so row has already violated
this constraint it has caused a conflict
so a conflict for a constraint is when
the slack goes negative
and note that in contrast to cdcl
we can get a conflict even though
all variables in it are not assigned
here we haven't assigned the solver
hasn't assigned
x1 yet but we already know that it
doesn't make any difference
whatever you do with x1 it's already too
late to repair
the previous mistakes
okay so good so then we know what slack
means and slack
pseudo boolean slack allows us to define
what it means to propagate
and what it means to reach a conflict so
now we can do
now we have what we need to lift cdcl to
lift decisions and propagations to a
pseudo boolean setting
fantastic next next up is conflict
analysis what should we do
let's look at this example cnn formula
we have
again and let's observe an interesting
invariant
that the when we have the trail with the
trail here is like from
from in chronological order from top to
bottom so here the trail is w
false u false x false y
true said true and
the assignment always we start out
with the assignment falsifying the
conflict
obviously so the trail falsifies the
conflict
but then when we do the conflict
analysis and derive
the first clause x or not y then even if
we remove
so we eliminate zed
from these clauses and we can pop it
from the trail and we see that
what remains of the trail is falsifying
this clause now the next step in the
conflict analysis we resolve over y
and we can remove y from the trail and
now we only have not a
w not u not x on the trail and that is
still
falsifying the clause that we have
derived at this point
so the invariant we're maintaining is
that at all points in time during the
conflict analysis
every derived constraint explains
why the assignment made so far was not
good
so clearly here this full assignment we
see it wasn't good because not y
or not said was violated but here we can
see that even this assignment w
0 u 0 and x 0 is not good because it
will violate
this clause which is a consequence of
our formula
so we can just because of this
environment we can keep going in our
conflict analysis and then
we just terminate it and learn the
constraint when we think that it looks
nice
and what's niceness well this is this
concept of being a first uip constraint
or an asserting constraint and what this
means that when we do the back jump
some variable is going to flip this is
an asserting constraint because when we
undo the decision on
x this clause will propagate that x
flips
okay so we just want to lift this to a
pseudo boolean setting
so first we have this resolution step
and we see that we can actually mimic
this
if we have x or not y or z
or and then not y or not z
and we want to resolve them to get x or
not y then if you just look at the
pseudo boolean constraints corresponding
to these clauses
and you add them up and you recall that
z
plus z bar cancels to the yield one
then you get x plus two y bar
greater equal one
and i will refer to this as as
generalized resolution when you have two
constraints
you possibly multiply them by something
to get a a a common coefficient for
for a clashing literal here we don't
need to to multiply because z has
coefficients one on both sides and then
you just
add them up and then here so here the
clashing literal is x1
so we multiply it by the least common
multiple c of a and b and multiply this
constraint by c
divided by a1 here we multiply by c
divided by
b1 and then we add and then we see that
x1 will cancel and we get this
constraint
so the math is a bit ugly but you can
look at this concrete example instead
okay
so this is in some sense generalizing
resolution
to pseudo-boolean constraints now except
that we didn't
quite get what we wanted because if we
wanted the clause
x plus y bar greater equal 1 but we got
a 2 here
so that was not quite right but if you
think about it if x plus 2 y bar greater
equal one is true
then since we're only interested in
integral solutions
zero one solutions in fact
the constraint x plus two y bar greater
equal one
implies x plus y bar greater equal one
so i can
from this i can deduce this note that
and this is what's known to the
saturation rule uh
which in more more in general says that
for any constraint in normalized form so
here we're using normalized form again
to define saturation
that if i have some a i l i greater
equal a
then you never need a contribution more
than a
so if you have any coefficients that are
larger than the degree of falsity then
you can decrease them to the degree of
falsity
and note that this is sound over the
integers it's not
sound over the reals
okay because over over the reals
this constraint is much stronger than
this constraint
um but since we're solving a boolean
problem we do need
rules that are sound over the integers
and and not over
just rational numbers or real numbers
because otherwise we would be doing
a linear programming with our
pseudo-boolean constraints and linear
programming is not strong enough
to solve a zero one integer programming
problem and in fact
the generalized resolution rule as
defined in hooker already includes this
fix
but for for this discussion that we're
having here today it will turn out to be
useful
to to separate the resolution step and
then the boolean saturation step
so now we're almost done i mean we have
we can do decisions and propagations
with slack
now we have generalized resolution and
then we can saturate so now we can try
to do conflict analysis let's do it
so here we have two constraints c1
2x1 plus 2x2 plus 2x3 plus x4 greater
equal
4. and then c2 which says 2x1 bar plus
2x2 bar plus 2x3 bar greater equals 3.
now if you think about that this is just
an obfuscated way c1
just says that a majority of x1 x2 x3
has to be
true and c2 just says that the majority
of them have to be
false so this should be unsatisfiable
and the question is how can we figure
this out
okay so let's suppose that a solver
starts with
x1 and sets it to
false then we realize
that so before we can first
as a sanity check we can see that the
slacks here before assigning anything
both uh constraints have slack uh
three which is larger than any
coefficient so
we indeed should make a decision there's
nothing propagating
and supposing that we decide x1 to false
now
c1 the slack went down from
3 to 1 which means that x2 propagates to
true and also
x3 propagates to true this is an
interesting property in the pseudo
boolean setting
a clause can only propagate once in cdcl
but in general the pseudo boolean
constraints can
can propagate many times so here c1
fires twice
and sets both of them to true and then
next we look at c2
and now of course c2 has x1 false which
is good but both x2 and x3 are
true and that is not so good so the
slack is in fact now
-1 that's a conflict so now we want to
do conflict analysis
so we know what we want to do we resolve
the reasons
uh the reason c1 we resolve it with c2
over the propagated variable
x3 and we use the generalized resolution
rule
and if we do the math we get x4
greater equal one okay and now this is
bad news actually
um oh we should also do saturation but
we already see that the coefficient is
one so saturation doesn't do anything
so why is this bad news well we derived
one interesting fact
to be sure we're deriving now that any
satisfying assignment to these two
constraints must set
x4 to true but
we wanted to derive
a constraint that explained what mistake
the solver did with its assignments so
far
and what we have left on the trail when
we removed x3 is that
x1 is false and x2 is
true nothing is speaking about x4 so x4
greater equal one is definitely not
explaining what went wrong it's not a
conflicting constraint
we broke our invariant
say so this conflict analysis did did
not work
so we failed so if you're bored at this
point in the in the
lecture because this this second part of
the tutorial is probably going to be the
longest part
and you know it seems that we're failing
so maybe you can stop watching this and
watch something else instead
suitable and conflict analysis doesn't
work too bad
or if you want to keep on watching with
me then let's let's see
let's let's try to see what went wrong
let's write an accident report and then
and
try to do something about this so what
went wrong first
so the observation is that actually
generalized resolution is just taking
positive linear combinations of
constraints and this happens to be sound
over the reals
so general resolution as such cannot see
any truths that are not true also over
the rules
generalized resolution does not do
boolean reasoning it's the saturation
rule that does boolean reasoning
so in this particular case we have the
trail x1 false
x2 true and if you look at it over the
reels then c1
is is getting a bit nervous
but it's saying okay so x1 is
contributing to
x sorry x 1 is contributing 0 x 2
is contributing 1. so we have a
contribution of 2. we need a
contribution
of 4 in total so we need 2 more but
generalized resolution says well you
know x4 could actually contribute
one and if i get a contribution
of one there then x3 only needs to be a
half
and this is actually why generalized
resolution reported that you know if you
can set
x4 to 1 then i think we're good
and c2 if you look at it in the same way
under the this is we resolved c1 and c2
and c2 says that well
i'm getting a 2 from uh
x one and i'm not getting anything from
x two
but i only need one unit more so if i
could just get a half
from x three then i get a half from not
x three and then i'm good
so both of these constraints in a you
know
real setting in a realistic setting haha
they're pretty happy actually and then
we
do the generalist resolution rule and x3
vanishes so that there's no trace of it
and how could we get a conflict because
generalized resolution doesn't
see a conflict like all of these
constraints seem to be happy
so that's i don't know if i'm saying
this in a good way but this is kind of
sort of my intuition for for why this
fails
so what do we need to do well we need to
make the reasoning
boolean and what is it that went wrong
well
one thing that went wrong is that c1
only
propagated x3
to a half and then the solver took over
and realized that well a half is not a
valid value so it set it
to to one instead but then what we did
the generalized resolution
rule this half came back and bit us
so it would be really nice if we could
get a reason that actually propagates
x3 all the way to one even over the
reels
if you think about what this means in
slack terminology we
would like actually the slack to be zero
because that says that
we can't just have a partial
contribution from this variable we need
it
to contribute everything in its mind
okay but the constraint doesn't have
slack zero so what do we do
well a fix that turns out to work
is to apply weakening and weakening is
you take a constraint
and then you remove a literal
lj from it here it is and
you say oh well how much could lj have
contributed well
aj obviously so i subtract
aj from the degree of falsity on the
right hand side
and if this constraint is true then this
constraint also has to be true but it's
a
weaker constraint because i've thrown
away the information about lj
but it also somehow the weakening step
what it does
is that it tells us that lj will
contribute the full boolean amount
and that somehow helps us to make the
reasoning boolean and this is
the approach in chai kulman that lies
behind how pseudo-boolean
conflict-driven solvers work
so what we want to do let's try this out
so we want to weaken the reason on some
non-falsified literal but not the one
that is propagated because we want to
resolve over that so if we weaken it
away then we lose the
possibility to resolve over it and then
we'll apply
saturation on the weekend constraint
because we always want to do that
and then we try to resolve and hope for
the best
so let's try so here we go again here is
the constraint
c1 we weaken it on x
2 which is a
non-falsified literal and then we get
2x1 plus 2x3 plus x4 greater equal to we
saturate nothing happens we resolve
again
and we get a constraint two x two bar
plus x four grade three equal one
bummer um this
is still not violated so we're not
maintaining the invariant of having a
conflicting constraint
so let's try to weaken even more what
else can we weaken
well x1 is falsified so we can't weaken
that
x3 is propagating that's what we want to
resolve over we could weaken away
x4 so let's weaken both of them
then we get 2x1 plus 2x3
greater equal 4 minus 1 minus 2
that's 3 4 minus 3 is 1.
and now note that now we can saturate
this constraint
there's no way we need the coefficients
2 here we can bring them down to 1.
and now let's resolve over x3 and now we
get 2
x2 bar greater equal 1. and this
in fact explains what went wrong
because the trail assigned x2
to true but this constraint says that
this was a mistake x2 should have been
assigned false
and now we haven't quite defined what
what
asserting or uip constraints are but it
should be clear that a unit constraint
that just contains a single variable
that is asserting so we can back jump to
top level
we can assert that x2 has to be false
and once we know that x2 is is
false then c1
will propagate x1 and x3 to true and
then we'll get a conflict again
and so we again have this situation
where we get a
contradiction at top level without any
decisions so now we can run conflict
analysis again
and derive um a contradiction
in in the form of the constraint zero
greater equal one or in practice in a
solver we would just terminate
immediately because we know
that when we reach a conflict without
having made any decisions then the
formula is unsatisfiable
so in general what we need to do
is we need to do this reduce the reason
before resolving
so um we while
while um we look at the resolvent and if
the slack
is not negative then we find some
literal in the reason
except the one that we're resolving over
some literal that is not falsified
we weaken the reason on this literal l
prime
and then we saturate and then we try
again
until resolving the
reduced reason with the conflict
constraint produces something that has
negative slack
so if we exit out of this loop then
clearly it works because
we are only exiting when the slack of
the resolvement is negative but how do
we know that we exit how do we know that
we don't crash
well very briefly the reason that this
works is that slack is
sub-additive
so if i have two constraints c and d and
i
multiply c by lowercase c and d
by lowercase d and then take the linear
combination
then their slack under row is less than
equal to c times the slack of c plus d
times the slack of d this is not an
equality so this is not additive but
it's sub-additive
okay and we know that on the conflicting
conflict side we have a constraint with
negative slack
and now um whenever we
weaken if you think about it the slack
of the reason
does not change because weakening is
assuming that literals
give the right contribution to the slack
and we're never
except that would not be true if we
weakened falsified literals but we're
not
weakening falsified literals so
weakening leaves the slack unchanged
so suppose that we have weakened away
everything and we're about to crash now
because
the while loop this test failed so far
but then what happens is that saturation
will decrease the slack and when we're
in the very last loop then there's only
the only thing that is left that we have
not weakened away
is the propagating literal l everything
else is either
falsified or has been weakened away and
now what is the
propagating uh what is the
coefficient of the propagating literal
well it has to be at least the degree of
falsity because
that's the only thing left contributing
and if
the coefficient of the propagating
constraint
was less than the degree of falsity then
we should already have a conflict but
weakening can never lead us into a
conflict
okay so the coefficient of l
is at least the degree of falsity and
then saturation brings it down so that
they're actually
equal and that means that the slack
the the very last time we're at the top
of this while loop
the slack will be zero so i'm going a
bit
fast maybe but again you can pause the
video recording
so then we're home that means that at
the very last
point in this while loop we have slack
zero on one
side slack negative on the other side
and then
here's the resolvent and by the sub
additivity of slack
we have something
multiplied with 0 plus something else
multiplied by something negative
so the resultant will have negative
slack
and this is why it works so the conflict
analysis now in a pseudo-boolean solver
will just be that
while the conflicting constraint is not
asserting
find the last literal uh assigned last
on the trail
in this conflicting constraint that
occurs
with the wrong sign in the conflict side
constraint
find the reason for it reduce the reason
resolve and saturate and keep going
doing this
then we maintain the invariant that's
the c confl is what we derive
on the conflict side and it's always
falsified by what remains on the trail
so we just do this until we like um
the conflicting constraint when it is
asserting then we learn
it and back jump this is essentially
sort of what lies at the heart of the
conflict analysis used in stat44g
and the only thing that changed from
cdcl is this
reason reduction line
so compared to cdcl one challenge
is that propagating is more complex it's
it's much
harder for propagating on a clause
there's this famous two watch literal
scheme which says that as long as you
for a clause no matter if it contains
two clauses or 200
two literals or 200 literals as long as
i know that a clause contains two
literals that are
unassigned
then it cannot propagate and i don't
care how large the clause is if i know
two literals in it that are unassigned
then it doesn't propagate this is not
true
obviously for a pseudo-boolean
constraint consider
sum of n variables being at least
n minus 1 then as soon as i set
one of these variables to false all of
the others will propagate to true so
i'll have to watch
everything to discover this another
problem is if you think about how the
pseudo-boolean conflict analysis works
this generalized resolution rule
does a lot of least common multiple
computations which means that the
coefficients grow
and coefficient sizes can explode and
make the
integer arithmetic very very expensive
and this is a
is a concern in in practice
an even more serious concern is if i'm
evil and i take a cnf formula
and we know that we can encode
disjunctive clauses as pseudo boolean
constraint so i can take my cnf formula
and just write it
as a collection of pseudo boolean
constraints with coefficients one
then it's fairly easy to verify that
actually this algorithm that i told you
about
will just be standard
conflict-driven clause learning so it
won't do it it will only learn clauses
so you never leverage the power of this
pseudo-boolean reasoning
but what you do is you have super
expensive data structures
and you only get cdcl so for cnf inputs
the pseudo-boolean solving
algorithm will be terrible
so what can we do about this well one
observation is that the cutting planes
proof system that i said that we were
going to use
in the literature there's nothing
such as a a saturation rule there's the
division rule which is sometimes
referred to as uh juatalgomori cut
although this cut terminology is a bit
tricky because
the term is used very differently on
them in a mixed integer linear
programming community
and and i think here in the in the
saturn proof complexity community so
it's safer
to just refer to it as the division rule
now
assuming normalized constraint again the
cutting planes
proof system can be defined as having
the following rules
all literals are non-negative we can
take
a linear combination of constraints with
positive coefficients
here we're assuming that things get
appropriately normalized and then we can
divide
so if i have a constraint sum a i like
to equal a
then i can divide everything by c and
round up everywhere and this constraint
will be valid
not over the reals but over the integers
interestingly cutting planes with
division
is an implicationally complete proof
system that means that if i have a
collection of pseudo-boolean constraints
that imply some other constraint
then this other constraint can be
derived
by cutting planes so anything implied
can be derived
however for cutting planes with
saturation this is not true so in that
sense scanning planes with saturation
maybe seems
weaker and it's a natural question to
ask whether
maybe division could give us a better
conflict analysis
so this is what we're going to talk
about next and this idea
has in fact been proposed in general
integer linear programming
earlier in the solver cut set
so let's
look at the same problem again c1 c2 we
have the same trail but now we're going
to use division to reduce the reason
instead so here's what we want to do
we uh we look at the coefficient
of the propagating literal so here the
coefficient is
2. we weaken
away all non-falsified literals with the
coefficient
not divisible
by this literal coefficient
and then we resolve or we we weaken
on on some such we weaken
on some non-falsified literal with
coefficient not divisible by
uh the coefficient of the propagating
literal
so i'll explain more about this in a
minute but let's see what happens so
here
again we have the the reason
and we're going to divide by 2 which is
the coefficient of the propagating
literal
2 does not divide 1
so we can try to weaken away x4 i mean
we already know that
resolving c1 and c2 doesn't work so we
have to do some weakening
so let's we can away x4 then we get
2 x1 plus 2x2 plus 2x3 greater equal 3.
now we apply division by 2 then we get
x1 plus x2
plus x3 on the left we get a half one
and a half
on the right which gets rounded up to
two and now when we resolve this
everything cancels and we get zero
greater equal one
so deep inside this is also another
difference compared to cdcl
deep inside the conflict analysis
suddenly boom we just derived
contradiction
and can terminate immediately so
it should be clear from this small toy
example that obviously
conflict analysis with division is is
better
that's not necessarily true you can
argue that maybe i chose this toy
example specifically and of course i did
but it does illustrate that division and
saturation works differently at least
so the division algorithm for
for reduction is we take the coefficient
of the propagating literal
and then we try to resolve again and if
the slack is non-negative
then we find some literal that is not
falsified
and is not divisible
by the coefficient of the propagating
literal we weaken
on that literal and then we try to
resolve again until we get something
with negative slack and then we're happy
and then we return
so okay great i mean it's if we return
then we're happy but why would we return
well again we're looking for a reason
with slack zero
if that happens then we're happy
and as before we're only weakening on
non-falsified literals so weakening
doesn't change the slack
so from the beginning we know that the
slack is greater equal
zero otherwise we would already have a
conflict but it's also strictly smaller
than c
otherwise l would not be propagating so
we know
that the slack is between
zero and strictly smaller than c
and the weakening steps don't change
this
and now let's do the same analysis let's
suppose that we weaken the way
everything all um
we have we can weigh all literals with
coefficients not divisible by c
and we're doing the final desperate
resolution
attempt and if this fails then we'll
just crash because there's nothing more
to weaken
why will this work well the observation
now is that
when we have done our weakenings
then anything that can cause
rounding up in the
left-hand side of the recent constraint
is eliminated
actually the only thing that remains are
all divisible by c
so there's no rounding so actually
the slack of
c reason divided by c is in fact the
slack
of this constraint divided by c
there's no rounding okay so that means
that
we can just divide by c everywhere and
we get that 0
is less equal than the slack is strictly
smaller than 1 or in other words the
slack is in fact 0.
so if not earlier when we have weakened
away
all literals with coefficients not
divisible by c
at that point we simply have
to get a conflicting resolve with
negative slack
again i'm going a bit fast but you can
try to do this
offline later or hit the pulse button in
the video
right now
um and as you saw in the proof we could
in fact weaken away
everything in one go if we wanted and in
fact
the way rounding sat was presented in
in 2018 was by
such a more aggressive reduction
algorithm that just takes all the
literals
that are not falsified and there are
with coefficients not divisible by the
coefficient of the propagating literal
and just weaken away all of them in one
go and by the proof we just did
we know that this is a good constraint
to resolve by
and in fact uh the rounding sat
conflict analysis does this round to one
both on the reason
and on the conflict side and also on the
learned constraint
so so the conflict analysis
will be something like this
so um
it seems now how does division compare
to saturation well it seems
that four formulas where this
sophisticated pseudo boolean reasoning
doesn't help it seems that
division-based conflict analysis is
faster
then the speed of conflicts is not it's
not as fast as in the in a
conflict-driven closed learning solver
but it's
much appears to be much faster than for
saturation based solving
when the pseudo boolean reasoning really
kicks in then conflict analysis slows
down
significantly but it seems to pay off
and
since you're doing division we don't
have this problem of coefficients
growing and growing and growing because
division will somehow tend to
keep them small and so in fact the
default mode
of rounding that is even to do just
fixed precision arithmetic
because most of the time coefficients
will stay small
so this is nice but division is not the
end of the story there are
some benchmarks for instance for for
multiplier circuit verification some
problems that were set for j is much
much much better
some problems that are not solved by the
division versus saturation choices well
propagation is still hard to do
efficiently
and also this division algorithm that i
showed you also degenerates to
resolution for cnf inputs
and and something that we'll talk about
later
uh in this tutorial is that uh
even when you have a pseudo-boolean
formula that is infeasible
considered as a linear program so you
don't even need
boolean reasoning to figure out that
there are no solutions there are no
real valued solution even even then
there are some benchmarks that are
really really hard
for both search for j and rounding set
so this ends the the part
where i discussed about concrete
approaches for suitable and conflict
analysis and now we
at least know the basics of how to build
a pseudo-boolean solver we have figured
out how to do decisions and propagations
we have now two ways of doing conflict
analysis either with division or with
saturation
so now we have like a functioning sudo
boolean solver to build on
now let's talk about some other possible
rules let's talk about some open
research problems
one interesting rule is
to round constraints to cardinalities
for instance suppose
we have a constraint like 3x1 plus 2x2
plus x3 plus x4
we can actually see here that
one thing that follows from this if this
constraint is true
then clearly at least two of these
variables have to be true
right so this constraint
implies the cardinality constraint sum
of x1 up to x4 is greater or equal to
and this is called
reducing or rounding to a cardinality
constraint
and the first solver pseudo boolean
solver that used this conflict analysis
with saturation in fact only learns
cardinality constraints it rounds
everything to cardinalities they're
easier to deal with and they're arguing
in this galena paper that most of the
extra power from pseudo-boolean
reasoning comes from
cardinality constraints anyway
not sure i necessarily agree with that
but
that's their conclusion after having
evaluated it
so formally the rule is that if i have
this general sudo boolean constraint in
normalized form
so again a i they're not negative a is
non-negative
then i can derive that at least t
of these literals have to be true where
t
is the minimal set i
such that if i sum over the coefficients
in i
i reach a so basically i just sort the
coefficients in order
and then i sum them up and the question
is how many coefficients do i need to
sum
before i hit the degree of falsity here
if i sort them in order
then just one coefficient 3 is not
enough because 3 is less than 4
but 3 plus 2 is enough because that's 5
that's greater equal 4.
so that's how i can
deduce that um at least two of these
variables have to be true but it's not
true that at least three of them have to
be true because if x1 and x2 are true
that's enough so i couldn't have a three
here but i can't have a
two so natural question is this is now a
new rule that we would like to add
turns out that this is not a new rule
it's easy to simulate with weakening
plus division
so in some sense if you want to round to
carnalities you
you already have it um although
the the conflict analysis that i showed
you will not do this of course so you
could
but you could do this for instance as a
post-processing step say
after conflict analysis
another interesting rule is
strengthening which i will
introduce by an example suppose i set x
to zero and i have these three
constraints and let's propagate
clearly x propagates a y to true
it propagates z to true and then let's
look at this constraint
this constraint is actually over
satisfied i mean i need to
get 1 on the left hand side but i have
2.
so from this i can actually conclude
that
x plus y plus said is greater or equal
to
why can i conclude this well either
um if x is true then i already know that
y plus z is greater than or equal one so
then definitely
x plus y plus z is greater than or equal
to
but what if x is false well if x is
false i checked that i got unit
propagation and over satisfaction so
then i also got two
so this is actually sound and note that
this is interesting these are actually
clausal constraints if you think about
it and from these clausal constraints
i can derive a general cardinality
constraint
and this is strengthening rule
apparently appears in operations
research
and more generally suppose if i set
some literal l to zero and i have some
previous constraint that i know is true
a but it gets over satisfied by an
amount k
then from this fact i can deduce that
another valid constraint is k times l
plus some a i l i greater equal a plus k
so what's nice with this in theory is
that you can recover from bad encodings
for instance if you had a strengthening
rule in your solver then you could get a
cnf
and then you can run this strengthening
rule and recover a better
pseudo boolean encoding that would allow
your solver to perform better
in theory in practice i don't know of
any solvers using the strengthening rule
it seems hard to get this to work
unfortunately another rule that we
discovered
in our group or my phd student stefan
goff discovered that it would be really
helpful is the following
and this so this is actually something
that happens in our solver
that you derive a constraint something
like 2x
plus 3y plus 2z plus w say greater equal
3. and then you derive exactly the same
constraint except that
x is false here everything else is the
same
by just looking at this you realize that
well if both of these constraints are
true
x is only contributing to one of them
right so in fact it has to be true that
you you can just remove x and say that
well 3y
plus 2z plus w that's great 3 equals 3.
okay the question is can we can we
somehow derive this
well we can resolve over x but that
gives us
this constraint six y plus
four z plus two w greater or equal four
and then you can try to saturate
or you can divide but you don't get this
constraint
so i don't know of any way of deriving
this with cunning planes
so here's like a more general statement
of this
let's call it fusion resolution rule and
we are not aware of any obvious way
of forecanting planes to derive this we
also don't know if it's impossible
it's just an observation that this
actually shows up
in some tricky benchmarks on
which pseudo-boolean solvers perform
fairly poorly
if you had this rule and if you could
somehow have the solver efficiently
detected which is another challenge
because the texture would have to be
really fast but then this would be like
a really
helpful rule
so what are some other challenges for
pseudo-boolean solving
one challenge is well we know
from a sad solving context that
pre-processing is really important
and in integer linear programming it's
called pre-solving and it's also very
important but pseudo boolean solvers
don't do it
uh and it seems that maybe on some
instances it's it's really hurting so
why not why aren't we doing
pre-processing for pseudo boolean
solvers so someone should do this
one idea is of course to take cdcl ideas
and try to use them
there's some preliminary work
in a by now fairly old paper and seems
like it didn't work well enough
to follow up on another idea would be to
take an interlinear programming
pre-solver papillo for instance from the
open source mib solver skip
and try to somehow integrate it with a
pseudo-boolean solver
another obvious problem that we already
discussed well what if your input is c
enough how could we get a pseudo boolean
solver to perform better
one particular way is to recover
cardinality constraints the
strengthening rule would do this as we
already saw
you could run it as a pre-processing
step this was done in a in a
2014 paper by biera at all although this
seems
more like it's expensive enough
that it wouldn't work in practice and
it's also not strong enough
we had a paper suggesting to do this
more like
on the fly as an improcessing step
during search
that works better in fact yields some
fairly interesting results
but still not enough to be competitive
in practice
it is not available in the solver
because it's not good enough another
sort of
anecdotal observation is that these days
cdcl solvers are fairly stable like if
you take
a formula and you permute it you permute
the variables flip the polarities maybe
it seems like not too much happens with
the cdcl solver
like the performance is is roughly the
same i mean obviously the formula is
semantically the same
and somehow the cdcl is already stable
enough to not get confused by these
permutations
it seems that pseudo boolean solvers are
much much much more sensitive to this
and i don't know why and i don't know
what to do about it
in conflict analysis uh well should we
do
division or should we do saturation or
maybe choose adaptively or maybe
should we choose some other boolean rule
from integer linear programming where
there are a lot of
cut um
there's something that i don't have to
go into but but a very intriguing
observation is that
the appearance of irrelevant literals in
in pseudo-boolean solving so i can just
go
back very quickly to this example we had
[Music]
when we did conflict analysis here for
instance you realize
that x4
is totally irrelevant here
it will never influence whether c1 is
true or not
okay so the the whether x4 is assigned
to be true or false is completely
immaterial
so and so so you could actually remove
this
from the constraint without affecting
anything that's a semantically sound
thing to do
so you can say but why why worry about
this well it turns out that since the
conflict analysis is so syntactic
these irrelevant literals can actually
mess things up
a lot in the conflict analysis and there
was a paper by the team in lance
showing that in fact irrelevant literals
do
show up in pseudo-wool and conflict
analysis and the question is
how bad is that and can something be
done about it
general observation is that there are
many many more degrees of freedom in
conflict analysis
then is the case for sat solving for
instance
it can be when you're doing your
conflict analysis that the slack is so
negative that you could actually skip a
resolution step
without resolving away the variable
clearly you couldn't do that
in a in a clausal setting because if you
don't resolve away
if you leave a literal unassigned in a
clause then the clause is no longer
falsified but as we saw
in a pseudo-boolean constraint it could
contain quite a lot of unassigned
literals and still be conflicting just
because the slack is negative enough
one question is this this somewhat
mysterious weakening step during
conflict analysis
how aggressively should we weaken should
we weaken the minimal amount the maximal
amount somewhere in between
is it better to learn just cardinality
constraints as in galena
or should we learn general sulubuna
constraints i'm not aware of any modern
thorough evaluation of this when you
learn an
asserting pseudo-boolean constraint it
turns out that it can actually be
asserting at several different
levels how can we detect this
efficiently which level should you
back-temp to
should you back-jump as far as possible
or
as short a distance as possible when
you're doing the integer
arithmetic should you go for for
large coefficients large position or
should you try to round down and keep
things in small position
lots and lots of these questions that
just don't arise in cdcl
they do arise in in the pseudo-boolean
conflict-driven solving
i don't think they have been
investigated except that in these
papers from from last that i'm citing
here they have done some work on this
but other than that i'm not aware of
much
so it would be interesting to get a
better understanding of this
another thing in in cdcl conflict
analysis
is that clause minimization is important
question is could you do some kind of
constraint minimization in a pseudo
boolean setting it's not obvious
this is a would be very interesting to
come come up with something that
works and this is related to all of
these questions are also related to when
i
when i have a pseudo-boolean constraint
how do i know whether it's good or not
for clause that's kind of clear roughly
speaking
if a clause is like smaller than another
clause then it's a stronger constraint
but a pseudo boolean constraints can
have many different dimensions there's
the the size of the coefficients
the number of variables in it so it's
not so clear if i give you two pseudo
boolean constraints
how can you tell which one is better or
worse
and note that this would be interesting
if you're for instance doing some kind
of
adaptive conflict analysis and trying to
choose between
division and saturation maybe you try to
do both and then pick the constraint
that looks better
but in order to pick the constraint that
looks better you have to be able to
answer
the question what it means that it looks
better
and also you can look at these different
conflict analysis methods and they in a
natural way they give rise to
subsystems of cutting planes and we
don't know
how these are related a very interesting
question is
is whether cutting planes when division
is
always strictly stronger than cunning
planes with saturation we do
know that there are instances for which
division
is stronger than saturation
where the proof system with division is
exponentially stronger than the proof
system with saturation
we also know that there are other
derivation steps where like saturation
can derive certain concrete constraints
much more efficiently than division can
but we don't know if the proof system
with saturation
is stronger for such instances than the
proof system with division
so we know that okay so division cannot
simulate
uh individual saturation steps
efficiently but maybe the proof system
with division can just get around this
and derive something completely
different
yes we don't know
in terms of solar heuristics there are
very well developed heuristics for cdcl
solvers
most of them i would say have just been
copied
to a pseudo boolean setting but
the question is since surubulen
constraints are more general maybe
the heuristics should be adapted like
how you do variable
selection how you bump variables
during conflict analysis this is related
to
you know giving variables scores brownie
points that they're currently
contributing to the conflict analysis
and these brownie points
will then make it more likely that the
variables get selected for decisions
one could consider different bumping
schemes
in a pseudo boolean setting depending on
whether the literal appears
falsified or unassigned whether it
cancels in the resolution step or not
another area in cdcl
where there have been developments is in
face saving
where the latest idea seems to be you
have like multiple
faces we don't have this in a
pseudo-boolean setting we don't know if
it matters
also since a number of years back in in
cdcl the conventional wisdom seems to be
that you should have different modes
for like sat focused search in cdcl
where the solvers tries to
zoom in on a satisfying assignment and
then it changes its mind and says well
no
maybe this was an unsatisfiable formula
after all and then it goes into an unsat
mode where it
tries to prove contradiction and it like
switches back and forth between
sat mode and onset mode should we do
this for pseudo boolean solving also
these are lots and lots and lots of of
open
problems where you could do a
combination of implementation work
and experiments and then try to analyze
and explain
and essentially nothing has been done
except there's a roman valence
thesis addresses some of these questions
highly recommended reading is an
in-depth investigation
but i think there's lots of follow-up
work to do
on this um
finally um as i already mentioned
several times now efficient unit
propagation for suitable and constraints
is hard
detecting during conflict analysis which
whether i have already
reached an assertive constraint is a
non-trivial problem
and in contrast to cdcl how could we do
proof logging how can we
certify that the results
that the solver computes are correct
and here i i should say that this is
something that i'm very very interested
in and that we're
working on um i would be happy to
to talk to you about it during the
simon's program we have
a uh proof checker that we call the
verypb that we're very optimistic about
that it will be able to do efficient uh
proof logging
uh for sudo boolean solvers and and not
only sudo boolean solvers but
but also other types of solvers but
that's
not the topic of of this tutorial so
this
ends this long long second part
of the tutorial on pseudo boolean
solving
thank you for sticking with me till the
end
now um what's next up
is to say okay fine
suppose we have a pseudo-boolean formula
and we're not only interested in
checking feasibility
or whether it's satisfiable there's also
a linear objective function that we want
to optimize so we want to find the
the solution which has the smallest
value according to this
linear objective that's what we're going
to talk about
next but this is the end of part two
of the tutorial on sudo boolean solving
and optimization
you